drones that act like a swarm of bees and
others that could hide from enemy radar
these are some of the latest remotely
operated military aircraft in china's
arsenal
we've seen sort of an explosion of
creativity from the chinese defense
industry
and beijing has said modernization
includes building more sophisticated
drones at a time of tension between the
us and china they want a military that
can employ artificial intelligence
autonomous systems and generally a lot
more unmanned systems
china's military spending is lower than
the us but beijing has been dedicating a
growing portion of its budget to drones
and other military equipment
and while chinese drones don't have as
much battlefield experience as the
american made ones we compare different
models to see how beijing is pushing new
designs and capabilities to better equip
its military for possible conflicts in
the region
since the 1930s the u.s military has
been one of the early pioneers of
unmanned aerial vehicles
today it flies a fleet of thousands of
drones that have operated in countries
including iraq pakistan and afghanistan
drones are going to become very
important in modern combat timothy heath
has been studying china's military
strategy for more than 20 years and is a
senior researcher at rand corporation a
non-profit organization that contributes
strategic analysis to the us department
of defense
drones offer options unavailable to
manned aircraft since they can be
remotely operated or autonomously follow
pre-programmed paths
there is a low risk of human casualties
you get the ability to loiter for
example and to use advanced sensors so
you can have more precise targeting in
general drones are lower cost than
manned aircraft
it's these capabilities that have made
china interested in expanding and
modernizing its own fleet they are
building on what the us military have
done the first generation of chinese
unmanned aircraft were pretty derivative
of the us
one of china's earliest models looks
almost identical to the u.s predator
drone and works similarly
both are remotely controlled via
satellite and can carry missiles
but china is also tweaking the design so
its drones are better suited for
wherever its military is likely to
deploy them
like the global hawk the chinese
military says the wz7 is capable of
operating at a high altitude to conduct
surveillance missions but the u.s drone
is larger and can fly for longer periods
of time allowing it to operate around
the globe to support air and ground
forces wz7 probably it is going to be
used mainly in the region or the
maritime space in the east china sea and
south china sea
in that area the chinese don't need as
long an endurance
what it does need is the ability to
navigate unstable weather conditions in
the region like typhoons so the wz7 is
designed with two sets of overlapping
wings that the chinese military says
create more airborne stability
besides tweaking designs china is also
rethinking how many drones it can deploy
at the same time
the golden eagle 150b can drop small
bombs and china has said it wants to use
several of them simultaneously it's kind
of like a swarm of bees where they all
each individual bee knows what it must
do and can make its own decisions if one
bee next to it gets killed the others
will continue
swarming to sting
china hasn't demonstrated these drones
but showed how the swarming tactic would
work with another aircraft the military
hasn't said how it will manage a large
network like this remotely
drone experts say the key would be to
program them with sophisticated sensors
to communicate with each other so they
approach the target together while avoid
crashing into one another if the
swarming drones can work in the real
world this cheaper unit could help
exhaust an enemy's missile defense
system
another creative approach china is
taking combines some of the best
features from multiple aircraft to build
something that's not in the us arsenal
china's gj-11 is a reconnaissance combat
drone that has some of the features of
an american b-2 bomber for instance a
flying wing design that allows the
airframe to deflect radar signals
china hasn't publicly demonstrated this
drone but he says it would probably rely
more on automation unlike the b2 bomber
which needs two pilots on board because
it's flying far from chinese command
centers it flies at a very high altitude
they would have to program in some
mission parameters and the gj11 would
rely on navigation capabilities and
target identification capabilities to
carry out its strikes behind enemy lines
there is definitely some distance
between development and deployment elsa
kenya is an adjunct senior fellow at the
non-profit and bipartisan theme tank
center for a new american security which
received some funding from the u.s state
department she's been studying china's
military tech innovation for about seven
years
the chinese military hasn't used its
throne in real warfare but over the past
decade the country has exported over 200
drones to 16 countries
they've been crashed there have been
complaints about the reliability but as
chinese drones are used by other
militaries that the data or the insights
generated from those use cases may
improve their designer development going
forward the chinese defense ministry
didn't respond to a request for comment
last year the official newspaper for the
chinese military said that drones are a
new experiment and a growing trend for
future combat
kenya says the newer models point to how
china could eventually integrate ai and
machine learning to improve performance
and make them highly autonomous but that
also raises questions about the security
of any ai driven drone there are ways
the drones can be hacked jam disrupted
with increased autonomy does come a
greater risk of a failures that are
unexpected or of systems that are
immature proving to be unreliable
despite all these concerns china is
quickly advancing not just the
development of drones but other parts of
its arsenal
and that could increase concerns from
the us and its allies in the region with
these drones what you'll see is that
chinese will be able to respond even
faster and more effectively it's
possible that a long-term effect of
increase china's use of uavs to dominate
its neighbors is
increased tensions between china and
many of its neighbors